if there is one stitch me the donald trump
made in and around
the g7 together in canada that stands out as
particularly
en fads is specially i never anything
historical and occur at the mare
channel like you read leaving the seventh
son
donald trump said the the united  states
mine and performance with sarkozy style live
demo pushing campmans
and or photo beliebers a brit in france
germany job and canada and you this
file be no charge period between them
in the united states
what speaks the style you look tense
i now a surinamese woman  was the
driver moment that it's not an empty
fred with around religions i think of doing
this and i just choose any professional
at six core white ii white
specialization okay who you those from the
countries a better off
not making every thing themselves that
they use when  making some things
and de importing others okay this is a
basic fundamentals them of economics der
is a major the beer about trade policy
so the beer about chairs over imp  ort
export als ie over economic isolation
smf finding the right balance leaving
boxes name x actors with the ideal
countries or better off doing some great
with other countries at least some
degree is a risk that slide and it
strings controversial economic ideal
the cancer version comes and  one you wanna
start concern also a cloud and rebuild
trade policy
fields with my mac marx cheaper in your
country
i love my coat aaron woters with
location right it starts ticket complex
and it starts students gruyère paul
grice verpinken mein kampf so
invigorating at so conversation
double charge weezer camp flex
economic issues with the concepts
specialize in peace between some extent
is it and it or modern western
democratic economic pyry and trump
streets and great badar allies des
dangers sdc color so strike builds
gram will measure
trump salto fellow man remove all terrace
of the white star trading with your all
together
er-a 3 kids of totally free trade ry  an
and i your ipad air france budge greens and
catholics scribe sam parasite you'd
the police is totally free trade and there
's a major the baby her about free
trade the problem is that most people who
claim to one free trade of really would
they  had a version also how free trade
at benefit stem
we dit chair whatsapp cities and
terrace where i benefit stem is wel en
de room with notes green application of
100% free trade and forget who are
wimps that i snap prakticon de
realisten knorr
typically beneficial in the  langres wat
der wiel problem is the trump just as
another fair trade is a zero sum
whatever your views on free trade or
protection so
en there is a long db db iw student
join snazzy euros
and their benefits to trade and
specialization and there  already costs in the
closet
arno [ __ ] money especially jobs and
very simple american exports to canada
support another country was six million
american jobs
discount 15 did is that word risking
over s lightray  the balance with canada
on him rather donald trump this this
would be self influence this economic
description of donald trump and die
steps with all for a life and my real
various
de picasso medium trump towers downey
went bar economics the last minute and
bamboo will at least me  campaigning
on we can wind radios again when i
had no reason to kill him a death
star trade wit of the seven all sure
why not something for dead american
first winding the double jump and
promising and he already do so has it already
you by the way  the arnie of trump to the
wine and the demanding free trade with
his bed if i don't get the moment that
cry for help whatsoever we just like the
exact op is refresh rate free trade
wines that knowledge or action free trade is
0 governmental barriers and regulations
that it stops the flow of goods and in
other countries
so trump is a dick free trade so badly
the hill and the fries reason all together
4 dongchimi my version free trade this is
no longer l  okken campi sodom
braille is potentially rather fresh brie
damage and relationships with a life but
over things
keep links will be good for the united
states which will actually be self
inflicted disaster site have managed to see
the comedy camp is camp with created with
the deaf  and this idea because there's
no actual economic defense for donald
trump is proposing here and the scary as
part of our website for
is dat neuron new songs from files
which if you decide the yes she is
watching of surprised system in the
american first thing i still  has known
for the persons tasting
that is really the scariest and above all
time girl u de discuss this story and
else from tv show on our
this talk shows up grab it which you can
access idea feedback my dot com slash
harry dietetics wit wide and  3 guys
will join the next discuss
do the president parking himself or no